tom brady so he's got a podcast with
gronk how cool would that be i haven't
started listening to that but i'm going
to now what is it that tommy and gronky
or tommy and gronk show they could call
it anything tommy and gronky podcast
and you know brady is just a different
person now he has just
taken on an entire new personality and
identity since he left boston and i love
it he's so much more interesting
remember when he just never said
anything he was so robotic it was really
impossible even to really embrace him
because he was so mechanical but now he
just says whatever now he's the one
throwing out 50 and saying what the hell
of course i can of course he can he's
got nine touchdown passes he leads the
nfl in passing right now he's not going
to do anything different going forward
he's going to be just as disciplined
with his diet and his exercise and
everything else he consumes and how he
lives his life 24 7. he could play till
50.
no no let me throw this out jordan you
might take the other approach so this is
what i i read with tom brady so he threw
um
or has thrown 154
passes in his touchdown passes in his
40s including postseason 154
in his 20s
he threw for 167 touchdowns he's 13
touchdowns away
from throwing as many passes in his 40s
that he has in his 20s that's three
weeks that's mine three games he's
499 yards away from breaking drew
brees's record for the most passing
yards in the nfl 499 he's averaging like
327. so let's say he throws for three
bills this week right plays the rams
good game week four
in new england sunday night football is
when he's gonna break the record for the
most yards in nfl history
it's a sunday night prime time game
bananas in terms of ratings super bowl
like ratings you can't you can't make
this stuff up you know i hope that
michelle tafoya or something whenever
brady throws that pass that breaks the
record like say it's in the third
quarter i hope she runs to belichick and
says you were the idiot that let him go
at the age of 42. how do you feel
ask him that question
mac jones looks okay i mean yeah i mean
listen uh here's the thing guys all
right the msnb espn put up a post uh
about how joe montana all right they
were just it was a juxtaposition between
joe montana and tom brady joe montana
threw 350 touchdowns in the passes in
his career tom brandy has thrown like
340 touchdown passes since he turned 35.
and it's just look we we have to we i
can appreciate tom brady and i do but we
have to also acknowledge this nfl is not
the nfl these guys played in the 80s and
the 90s tom brady has not gotten hit
maybe once in his career the way joe
montana got hit every single weekend i
watched leonard marshall of the new york
giants jim burke split joe montana in
half he didn't play for two years
because of that hit it went down as a
fumble it was a completely legal hit
that changed the game nfc championship
game in 1990 if i remember correctly
that
would get leonard marshall suspended
today it would be a 15-yard penalty
there was a player over the weekend
where justin herbert was ruled down in
the grass on a pass he completed yeah it
almost cost it probably cost him the
game he completed the pass
we are a step away from flag football so
with all due respect and tom brady's
amazing and we did talk about technology
when last time i was on a couple weeks
ago last time i was on with you
you know these are this is not kenny
stabler smoking a cigarette in in the uh
if you're in halftime guys that weren't
didn't come up working in the coal mines
from the days they were 12. there's no
reason yeah that somebody can't play to
them no and and maybe even 50 but i
think that you know we all know that
right the game has changed so much it's
just evolved with quarterbacks the rules
have changed so they can play longer but
i think the biggest story here is
belichick could have kept on winning
super bowls yeah but he chose not to he
chose to reset his franchise because the
salary cap was going to get out of
control and also what belichick really
did that was screwy is that tom was
helping him cheat
right this is the part about tb12 as an
agent you should know this tb12 he
leaves about 15 million dollars on the
table in
salary every single year how many times
has tb12 been the highest paid
quarterback in the league
never never but
he's making 25 about 25 million now is
he gonna make 25 million for his five
years well this is this is the okay 25
million what what's dak prescott making
right now 40. okay so tom brady should
be making what 50 mil a year against the
salary cap how does the players
association let this happen how does how
does the nfl
he allows it to happen because he's
smart he doesn't want to talk
i used to i used to get really mad at
eli manning when he was the high he's i
believe still to this day eli manning
has made more money than any player ever
in nfl history which is asinine but i
used to say the same thing i was like
toyota's paying you 50 million dollars a
year you need a left tackle take 10
million less get yourself a left attack
he's not making that we talked about it
i know that hyperbole but he's not
making 50 million a year but point is
off the field but the point is with tom
i get a different error than protecting
the quarterback
but he's not stupid he doesn't get hit
he didn't get hit in new england he's
not getting can't hit the wide receivers
either
they got you can't hit the wide
receivers either like they used to they
got they got to stick them on the gloves
now i mean look i'm not taking anything
away i'm not a tom brady hater i'm just
saying call it what it is well yeah but
hey the other thing is there's 31 other
quarterbacks playing with those same
rules this is he's the only one doing it
at the age of 45. look look at look at
every every breeze looked old ben
roethlisberger looks old even though he
okay in week one had a bad week too i
hear you man i look i i'm not say taking
anything away from tom brady i'm a
massive peyton manning fan and his last
year in denver he was all will he was
all intelligent and he was throwing
lollipops he took a hell of a lot more
abuse than brady has in his all i am
saying is that when you're comparing and
there and this is what we all do now for
some reason every conversation we have
about sports is yeah but is he the
greatest of all time yeah yeah sports we
have to do that you have to do it you
he's the gr all sports are era all
sports are error related i i agree i
hate the arid eric okay seriously well
how do you guys feel about it when
someone tries to make the argument that
bill russell's the greatest basketball
player of all time he was the greatest
basketball player of his era see the
this is this is my name
talking about people that actually say
that bill russell is the greatest player
josh is saying that he was playing
against you know firefighters and
lifeguards and stuff like that and it's
like you don't think that this dude if
he had access to the same technology you
did if you had access to the same
nutrition and supplements that you did
same coaching that you did he wouldn't
be just as great well this is more like
the babe ruth ohtani kind of
conversation right babe ruth oh he's
he's the greatest he's the greatest well
babe ruth was playing against farmers
and
for sure i've never heard that farmers
play baseball in the off season
jeff i like that i heard blacksmiths you
know uh country strong for sure harvest
there was no there was no um
talk about diversity no diversity no
dominican players you never even had to
play at night right he never had to deal
with lights but then people be like oh
you know you don't cross-country flights
yeah come on you know brady's gonna put
some of these numbers so out of reach
lefty's special that's the difference
right so brady is so far like i hear you
but at the end of the day he might be so
far okay like in his 40s
the
next closest player who's thrown um the
most touchdowns in his 40s is drew brees
57. now okay 57. now you're opening up a
whole another bag of worms there
gentlemen when was the last time is it
bag or is it candy
i don't know where did you get your
worms i don't get one
yeah
what did you just say the henley tine i
didn't hear any time oh anytime at that
time
that somebody is that far outside of the
bell curve yes what almost always comes
out that they were doing something that
everybody else isn't doing yeah so it
certainly happened in baseball
it happens in baseball it happens in
football it happens and yeah but brady's
got that
around him right
yeah like i mean but you yeah he takes
four gallons of water and then looks
then looks faster
it is true because you but you want to
believe it you know and then you find
out later that mark maguire and jose
canseco and sammy's so-so
yeah i don't know but you know what
that's not what this conversation is the
the shoe to drop with tom brady it's not
gonna be steroids i mean what's gonna
happen that he took you know illegal
avocados no like if i had well look this
it it's ridiculous
from mexico he bought him from it's
ridiculous for me to speculate but i
would imagine he's at the top top top of
his game steroids are like so old-school
guys like everybody's taking some
legitimate steroid at this point you can
mask anything you can do stuff in hours
before the test again and be fine you
know insulin is naturally occurring now
you can take insulin shots to make sure
that your body metabolizes fat there's a
million things that you can do i would
suspect if i now this is no allegation
i'm just saying if i were like oj like
when he wrote that book if i had killed
her the if if i had access to the stuff
that tom brady has access to
i think uh
growth hormone and stem cells would be
pretty much everything i think growth
hormone and stem cells are the fountain
of euthanasia you know the other thing
that's interesting about brady
because of his longevity and because of
the success is how many other people
have been able to hitch their wagon to
him and then become great forgetting
torah's meniscus in his 40s also yeah
yeah and and no one really knew about it
until the end of the year but like look
at bruce arians now how you're going to
judge him in a couple years two-time
super bowl champion probably great
quarterback of position coach and then a
great offensive coordinator for the
steelers you're just calling it for
tampa bay already nah but i'll tell you
what it's gonna it's gonna take a lack
of interest from them or some injuries i
think for them
they're clearly the best team in the nfl
right now
game season yeah i know i know i know
we'll say we'll see but his elbow his
shoulder something should give but maybe
you're right maybe something comes out
yeah okay why are you guys always
defending bill belichick what the hell
i want michelle tafoya to ask him that
question hey you're the one that let him
go at the age of no one's defending
one thing that bothers me
was it so boring winning super bowl
hey thanks so much for checking out that
short clip from sports now with tom
zenner if you want to see another short
clip click right here or if you want to
see the entire episode click right here
thanks for watching everybody
[Music]